tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vigenti oggi siamo sul knight i
seven potuto pensare come se dicessi
invece 97 io il mio inglese proprio che
renzi dopo un altro mondo il fissaggio
97 definito ragazzi ma anche altri
episodi al centesimo episodio il più
atteso della vita di gesù comunque sia
passiamo ai livelli visto che ormai non
mi stupisco di niente calde kidnapper
uccidi kidnapper echi ciao kidnapper è
morto si è suicidato ma che cazzo vuole
la mia vita c'è già che si uccide la
sola devo fare anche un lavoro sporco
non ho capito ecco adesso è morta in più
se filato al macedone al culo peggio se
dite è non ho capito il senso di allora
adesso mi spiegate con quanto culo sono
riusciti a beccare solo il bambino solo
lui è impossibile
devi morire di rumori o cioè è morto e
che cosa è cambiato rispetto a prima
spiega ho solo vinto ma non è cambiato
niente ai ragazzi i livelli dei fiumi
sono diventati così ultimamente c'è non
ho capito se joe sebastiano 500 io zio
trova di un nickname
e anche una ragazza per cortesia poi non
è che devo parlare io è per carità di
dio però sorge a save one
adesso voi vi fermate un attimo proprio
e apprezzate con me questo tiro ma che
cazzo ci propone anche zlatan non sa
fare se qualche cosa sei un
contorsionista è luca ce l'ho fatta a
farla non so neanche come fallo questo è
fallo e arbitro ea fallo perché non c'è
manco più a testa
io darei un bel rosso qui e swing my
first mother amico mio se l'hai fatto
per primo re di mi bacia bene perché c'è
gente che fa dei rock swing che
veramente sono denunciabili dalla vita
lynn è uno spoiler in data voleva
scrivere lino o win ieri son bari to
clear capitan uniti sono bari tu porca
[ __ ] baratta tipo di lanciare senza
fare troppe storie zio niente dove stai
seduto ok o per questo volevo fare da
un'ora e mezzo bravo quanta maestria
nell'ultimo livello non lo so perché
cioè l'ultimo tentativo bravo g la
madonna mi sembrava strano
sta andando troppo bene ma non devo che
i cani sto morendo
ci sono luoghi quella allora il primo
c'è lo zio mi chiami sono salvato per
cui issimo alla fine perfetto per questo
questo è un grip ho vinto con le gambe
ho vinto quindi va bene per carità di
dio è primis park fatto da super dragon
10 c'è un super dragon 10 fammi vedere
che bel livello e bellissimo che la
scritta si muove con lui il fantastico e
ti stai divertendo gli occhi ma guarda a
credimi sono contentissimo che tu ti
stia divertendo per carità ma cazzo fate
incastrarmi in un'altalena zio sono
giochi per bambini di due anni verdini
non fare figure di merda
salta cioè io sono la persona che riesce
a crepare anche nei parco giochi anzi
non seriamente capiamoci perché poi
difficile la situazione non riesce su
pressi delle altalene renditi conto ma
qual è il problema ha cambiato che
abbiamo personaggio che ho scherzato
fino adesso facciamo il padre o per
chiaramente tristissimo
se c'è un host altalene di così
difficile madonna ma perché solo nelle
cazzo realtà adesso steve salto tutto
nuovo santo tutto il livello non vorrei
capire o mi piace in scivolata devo
saltare l'este case
ma perché c'è un muro invisibile di
sopra cercata il frate dai sono a destra
tale meno vietato parlare dalle balene
nessun piede le altalene che cazzo fai
dai ma perché va su una porchetta o pop
madonna logica sì la vita della vita
incredibile ragazzi son riuscito a fare
un operaio dell'altalena mi sento una
persona realizzata la brava non si è mai
troppo vecchi per divertirsi vai a
morire nelle altalene che sono diventate
nella nuova macchina di tortura 2016 no
non ci torno io lì e non ci torno io lì
ma i cameo jeremy io che la prima cosa
si chiama e luke sto tizio prima cosa la
seconda cosa è morto mi dispiace signora
perché ci sono i folletti nel parco a si
chiamava polizia siete troppo grandi per
a dare il parco o quelli che fanno il
picnic romantico che dolci peccato che
la tua ragazza abbia perso la verginità
in questo istante mi dispiace zio lo so
che sei depresso dati al vino e non cac
armi con gli anni ragazzino capito il
senso visto livello ma cosa fanno
limonano apre che cosa triste ha mai
tradito brutta [ __ ] e non possono anche
ucciderli e perché ha voluto uccidere
lui ma perché già è affranto a livello
sentimentale devo anche ucciderlo ma
porino da aids o luigi gresta run to say
luigi ciao luigi non mi ricordavo così
così mi ricordavo tipo mezzo idraulico
come mario se vuoi fare la fila la fila
possono passare avanti sì tanto lei era
una volta era un parco adesso è
diventato reese un mcdonald che abbiano
arriviamo anche a casa mia è talmente
lungo sto livello avrà fatto anche casa
mia
a parte che è durato 280 secondi sul
livello ma parte quello perché il tipo
sta offrendo un anello allo pesa e c'è
babbo natale che dice bastardo chi è che
ha fatto sto livello sale dei problemi
sentimentali zio
minecraft sua happy wheels ho trovato il
diamante sono una persona fortunata del
vinto la vita e ho trovato il diamante
ma perché c'è un diamante sull'erba
da quando avete mai visto un diamante
preso in modo così acrobatico in
minecraft bene io no one pashmine ma
cover o poi ci mette saitama velista lo
aveva fatto benissimo premi contro il
pedale pugno alla femi che lo provarci
magari un momento memorabile questo è
giuseppe manata miei [ __ ] gli ho
dato affermi che dorme now dio sto tirar
manata alla gente di arola la mamma mi
chiamerà così potente anche nell'anime
ho fatto casino però l'importante è aver
vinto completamente fatto era fatto da
dio slog omen ragazzi sappiamo il nuovo
team nome per i personaggi di happy feet
logo man se sarebbe chiedono come
facciamo e come l'alzheimer non mi
ricordino amici e steve sipro slogan
meno un cazzo perché non si scappa addio
ricava molto un'idea provi prova a
vincere da sotto non so se riesco può
essere più difficile di quello che
sembra infermieria da ma devi lasciare
ecco bravo
fai cagare
fermi bravo lanciati dal ct qualche
merda cielo quasi recano affermi che
forse ce la faccio
[Musica]
ho toccato l'ho toccato la vedi su tutti
è che ho toccato tutti avete visto vinto
vinton aveva capito ma cede sopra però
dovrebbero ragazzi sono in è più visto
avrebbero mettere che si vince anche se
tocchi il traguardo da solo perché a
fine sempre traguardo è vero che ti deve
morire il criceto trio chi deve morire
criceto non lo so volete spararmi anche
vostra madre e già che ci siete o non ci
arriverò mai rega impossibile e mi sono
appeso
beh perfetto l'aver ai lasciam perdere
ragazzo livello da tanto l'ho vinto
passando di sotto avete visto tutti no
problem wwe make a move the pops
oddio ma mica che mossa è questa in
gruppo la il collo soli re make a move
no va bene che ho inventato il nuovo la
nuova mossa il colpo di culo
non so perché non non si è svenuto
niente ho vinto è bastato toccarlo ha
già vinto vieni giova star do niente
recano non esplode però stranissimo dai
ragazzi per concludere facciamo un paio
di miei livelli perché dio mi ha ancora
non ho visto roba decente fra vj sasso e
cavallo il fake di favino raga io
veramente mi fanno ridere di certi certi
livelli oriente fa vincere muori pezzo
di merda eh vabbè produce la mamma
[ __ ] facciamolo lo stesso giusto per
capire clicca qui per vincere
mi piace essere pro di cui deve avere
più di otto anni
poi c'è impossible episodio 96 ceo
questo è il 97 prove d'attore notato
adesso che la moneta è una pizza
cioè io io ho notato questa cosa adesso
che siamo al novantasettesimo episodio
il che è grave ma proprio che tanto
grave altro così stronza vita nel senso
non la puoi neanche prendere che
impossibile che grazie che in prossimo
magari questo l'ha preso troppo alla
lettera imposte deve essere imposti col
ma non vero fa vj versus john cena e con
questo chiudo ragazzi perché schiaccia
non si sa già a john cena un maschio
primo prima cosa che cazzo e sta tipa
seconda cosa e io non sono un vecchio ok
quindi non sa che quello che meno mi
rappresenta problema seguito vi è
piaciuto ragazzi cosa no vabbè però dai
pagani
io vado avanti più non capisco le è più
lì se lo dico da da da sempre questo
però continuerò a dirlo anche dopo il
centesimo episodio che i ragazzi si
parla che vide vi sia piaciuto lasciato
un bel la x6 volete arrivare al
centesimo episodio solo se bombardate di
likes non lo farò mai
intanto mi sta sudando anche il pube
strana stare solo è più il perché mi
eccito più ragazzi se vi è piaciuto
questo momento è un mi piace anche a
facili facebook e che mi voglio tornare
al tizian e certificate ci vediamo al
prossimo vita dei ragazzi